or Muhammad and her family of five have
been living in this refugee camp in
Northern Syria for the past five years
as a widow a Muhammad relies on Aid that
flows through the Babel Hawa Crossing
for their survival
the UN mandated program brings food and
other Aid through neighboring turkey
it is vital for the survival and
well-being of millions of syrians like
oh Muhammad
every passing year things seems to be
getting worse I have to support my
children with the help I'm getting but
it's gradually decreasing right now
we're just making do with what we have
and we don't have any other ways to earn
money it's really exhausting and I worry
about how we'll manage to survive in the
upcoming days
Muhammad's tireless effort to support
her children has become increasingly
challenging
because of the lack of resources
inadequate help leaving them trapped in
a cycle of desperation
currently we at least have access to
medical assistance clean water and
regular Food Supplies nevertheless for
families such as mine lacking any
additional income the absence of these
resources would undoubtedly lead to
starvation closure of the crossing would
signify the end of life for thousands of
internally displaced individuals
humanitarian organizations estimate more
than 2 million display syrians are
living in camps like these with a
majority depending on U.N facilitated
Aid
but the U.N security council's failure
to renew its mandate and keep the aid
coming is putting many at risk
activists are urging the International
Community to take action and prevent the
closure of the border crossing
right now many refugee camps are left
without any support at all ngos are
trying their best to meet the needs but
services like health care and shelter
are slowly being reduced without proper
U.N intervention this could potentially
Mark the beginning of a disaster if the
crossing isn't reopened especially since
the area is still suffering from the
ongoing War
the future of families like on
Muhammad's hang in the balance
as they say deliveries represent a
glimmer of hope the midst of their
hardships
Babel Hawa is a Lifeline for millions in
Northwestern Syria especially those
living in refugee camps if it were to
close the already dire humanitarian
situation would get worse that would
mean increased hunger and disease as
well as hindering the efforts of
humanitarian organizations to reach
those in
needleb Northern Syria